belle a tutti ragazzi veneti avessero
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo su
stupidella che sarebbe questa tipa
strana comunque prova a vedere come
funziona giusto dovrebbe essere tipo sin
d'ora è la legge ora la vera storia di
cenerentola vorrei capire un attimo il
senso devo commentare io manco quello
che cenerentola si trovava al ballo
serale dove c'erano dei pelati elvis
presley mentre succedeva tutto questo
l'orologio scoccò la mezzanotte
dopodiché mi arrendo questa cosa qui che
avete visto
i'm stupidella ma perché al dorso po di
intimo addosso ma bisognoso play che è
meglio stupidella fantastico partiamo
con stupidella perché a sardara questo
il menu comunque è un eroe tipo tra il
face quest solo più figo credo perché è
un po pignocca lei dei troll comunque
primo livello ragazzi stupide 9 bei
colori comunque mettono una voglia di
vivere incredibile 897 si giorno vado
avanti perché non mi parla normalmente
in un cazzo di vestito addosso per
parlar un questa rosa deve file a ok non
dovevo sputare la canna sul ho capito l
avesse sputa sta roba che cazzo devo far
scorta zia tela devo togliere questa ha
fumato amica mia adesso possiamo andare
a comprare un paio di scarpe è un
regista ma c'era cestino amica a dirlo
prima cose a caso la showgirl andiamo
avanti next level giorno mai visto una
[ __ ] del genere vero stavolta zio ma
vorrei tipo abbracciarti pro con trovato
un bazooka quindi come non detto
come si fa a far del male a una bella
giovane come me come come ti sei
permesso con la spada niente proprio un
cazzo solo fare questo ti faccio un tubo
a una bottiglia
la faccio rogazzo siamo dorme ecco vedi
sei vestita e anche abbastanza
guardabile però mercato mai a casa che
sveglia brutta e questa segnava la luce
perché che c'è il vibratore sotto le
coperte ha però qualcosa
spengo la luna cioè io posso tirare giù
sole a mio comando fantastico che si può
fare allora
ma chi è perché io so come svegliare le
donne c'è un cane che tenta di stuprare
amica mia famiglia pieni fai capire come
si finisce in queste situazioni perché
non lo so manco io devo fare
sui cartelli sì abbiamo cliccato un
cartello a casa
ovvio non sarei tanto scontento di
essere seguito da una tipa così prova
andiamo avanti che è meglio so suonare a
jimi hendrix non era un cazzi confronto
[Musica]
larga incredibile one direction se mi
sembra un po esagerato sta cosa la
tromba sì ho vinto che ebbe ma perché
sono troppo forti grazie ragazzi non
facciamoci domande click the difference
addio tra le differenze tigo manca il
fumo e fumo il fumo c'è che cazzo ne so
the pop no
ho intenzione di fare che ne so io quali
sono le differenze c'era scritto clicca
le differenze e dovevo cliccare la
scritta le differenze
io vi uccido i parenti tesoro non è
proprio il massimo ma donante bella usd
i miei soldi tutti e tutti i miei soldi
a pagare il giusto tra 10 e ci avrei
scommesso la vita nel cascata a
bottiglia beh ragazzi ce lo fa non so
come ma ce l'ho fatto va bene che è una
bomba era una bomba che devo fare in 10
secondi
mio dio vabbè mica che ansia maraga
maestri livelli non li capisco che cosa
vuoi fare in dieci marcato no ai veti ma
la roba tipo taglia il filo blues filo
rosso sarà un cazzo da noi
[Musica]
caso cerco so clicca c'è ma beh non è
possibile è andata bene che non so come
ho fatto
la madonna non so come ho fatto a veder
non ho idea
lo mancata di un millimetro e un cielo
che caga che ma è una specie di
indovinello qualcosa non capitola
ragazzi non ho capito devo buttarli giù
tutti in poche parole solo te ma perché
questo caga date minamata non dove è
allora che cazzo mente degli squali
comunque a parte sta roba madonna
fenomeno ok ok non calcio 9 euro per
l'eccidio 10 10 modo beccare il 10 no
questa devo fare probabilmente devo
beccarmi le chiappe o qualcosa non lo so
se devo clicca cos'è è la madonna
sindaca esagerazioni mamma quando la
classe non è culo lorenzo lorenzo
i figli stanno incoraggiando grazie
ragazzi non c'è bisogno però è infatti
vedi che non serve a niente
look a parte il fatto che che erano
brava la madonna che fenomeno non ho
capito come ho fatto ma poche domande
ragazzi avanti che mail ma io non ho
capito perché sono 13 livelli che questa
è nuda sarà un motivo se guarda mi
chiamo esce samara dal televisore
lo sapevo lo sancho avrei scommesso
qualsiasi cosa nel mondo vabbè il caffè
cassetti nel muro c'è qui spiega adesso
sbatte la testa fattori cassetta fissa
dimora
la posta devo fare ragazzi e poi la
stupra a caso no no no ti prende ti
prendo a schiaffi
pensavo riportarli dalla sportellate in
faccia ma non posso c'è un tasto no no
hai rotto il ca miglia all'ora cosa sei
serio ma veramente bello era capito o
gesù santo ti ringrazio reggiseno michia
non ci posso credere che questa cache ha
comunque campate sta roba
se devo fà devo ringraziare imbellire le
persone fatemi capire miss mondo ha
vinto perfetto vabbè ma e riguarda sé i
semi e bello se sei vestita per favore
metti un cazzo di vestito niente è
doverso amico mio
avrei tutti sti muscoli maio agli airbag
qui quindi non ci ho vinto io l'ho a
prescindere non so se lo sai ma non si
picchia alle donne stronza di merda ma
ho capito qualcosa di quello che ti ho
detto che volta mike tyson perché ci hai
un culo al posto del mento gancia lina
da botta in faccia fa qualcosa niente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì lo so click alle tette le tette
perché perché avevo anche detto che
erano quelle la soluzione dei vostri di
controllare 10 stupia ci sono 10 12 34
questo è un altro questo è piton
1 sì ci avrei scommesso è poi l'ultima e
lei e lo sapevo sei bellissima ragazzi
ho vinto sono troppo forte basta gara di
nuoto si può partire vai così lo ha
davvero a casa è morta incazzo fa volta
cazzo ma qualcosa va beh da ora su il
mattino prima che vai perfetto è magia t
ok ho vinto lo fa ma non si è mai troppo
prudenti in giochi del genere che bella
vista magari si aprì la porta prima
perfetto ecco adesso puoi
fatti è mancava devo prendere anche il
paracadute che ce l'hai qui perché
adesso poi saltare aprista roba perfetto
per ma anzi con lo zio ma vi sia sicuro
siamo quasi alla fine ragazzi siamo al
19 mancano due però non ho capito cos'è
la palla di fiat ma perché ci sono gli
alieni ma norma perché ho cliccato gli
anni e sono un deficiente delle scale a
caso a consigli a lei non mi possono pre
madonna quanto sei bello ho vinto anche
all'ultimo livello ragazzi voglio vedere
la genialità di questo sono in un razzo
devo andare nello spazio che finiscono
tutti nello spazio sti giochi non ho mai
capito starter ali manovra prima devo
attivare propulsioni viva attiva a
qualcos'altro e di start perfetto ma ho
vinto l'astrofisica che è successo è
successo se dovrei fare nella vita io
farmi capire ma devo andare nel latte
allora il senso di questa volta sono
andato nello spazio e poi sono andato
sulla luna che è popolata da teletubbies
tubi continua e mica c'è anche un
seguito ragazzi non voglio sapere qual è
il seguito prova bene stupidella best in
game 2015 have a look ragazzi con collo
che l'episodio è stato bello spero di
giocare anche a seguito di questo
meraviglioso gioco i ragazzi se il vino
è piaciuto non sentire soprattutto mi
piace anche a face di facebook e come
nemmeno a trattare sezione source e nei
vari siti skateare i cibi da un
professionista belle ragazze